we're going to look here at some
headlines coming across from Senator
John McCain in light of what we heard
last night at the presidential debate
Donald Trump asked if he would respect
the outcome of the election he's saying
in effect to chris wallace of fox news
the moderator of that debate i'll
surprise in other words not saying in
fact that he would respect the results
of that election John McCain Senator
John McCain saying here in a statement
he who disliked the outcome of the 2008
race but had he says the duty to concede
adding Americans should be confident in
the integrity of election so what would
a contested election mean for the United
States for the democratic process let's
ask Bloomberg's been Brody who joins us
from Washington DC Ben this is had an
incredible fallout this one line from
the debate last night but leading up to
it there had been concerned about
whether or not Donald Trump would
respond what's the latest today sure
absolutely well that statement that you
just talked about was a powerful one
John McCain obviously the 2008 nominee a
very popular figure within the party and
he talked about American exceptionalism
and he talked about the vote being a
respect for the will of the American
people is very powerful the latest today
is Donald Trump is continuing to talk
about rigged elections he accused
Hillary Clinton of having received the
questions beforehand that was a little
unclear if he was talking about the
debate last night or that Town Hall back
in March where it seemed like she might
have gotten a bit of a heads up on what
was going on now he is scheduled to make
his first event after the debate in just
a few minutes he'll be in Ohio that key
battleground so we'll see what his
message is but so far he is not backing
away from that rigged election stance
and that he may or may not be going
along with the results especially if
they don't favor him yeah Ben I mean
it's great that Senator McCain came out
and said this but you would anticipate
that you know everybody would be saying
this will trump come out and have a
clear message on this or really continue
to fudge the issue and Willie will there
be desertions from his stuff it's a
little bit unclear right now certainly
the last time there was a sort of round
Trump's candles things that he said that
were beyond the pale we had a few
Republican defections and then a few
days later they came back so it's
unclear if down-ballot Republicans want
to go out and then come back what we
have heard though are his staff and
surrogates trying to moderate this
message either they said they are saying
simply flat-out contradicting him that
he will absolutely accept the results of
the election or they're trying to sort
of moderate it even a little bit more
that he will probably accept them as
long as they're certified and he's made
sure that there isn't fraud so you see
him trying to modify there now whether
or not he's going to have a clear
message it's Donald Trump and from day
to day he can hit the same theme / and /
or he couldn't change completely it's
very difficult to predict what he may do
but it is a message that certainly
amplifies and motivates some of its
supporters and so it may be one that he
continues to hit especially if his poll
numbers continue to not look so great
for november eighth then put into
context for its this moment on the
campaign timeline we've now had three
presidential debates the vice
presidential debate there over what
happens next what are these candidates
gonna be pushing for here in the next 19
days as Bonnie said earlier absolutely
what it basically is is a scramble from
state to state you have to hit those
battlegrounds over and over and over
again this is the time when the trail
reporters they visit three or four
states even in a day you need to make
sure that you are organizing your
supporters down to the precinct level
you are determining who's going to come
out to vote who could come out to vote
who requested an absentee and hasn't
returned it yet you need to be doing all
those things and coordinating closely
with the state part